e aí galera capricho meu ronaldo banco
vocês comigo está tudo uma maravilha
graças a deus ninguém tem gente se
incomoda com as propagandas do show que
eu faço mas tem gente que quer ver para
saber se a sua cidade está no show no
entanto aparece na agenda de show do
resto do ano aqui na tela ou cepal sair
de sua cidade a nordeste os ingressos
neste site está aparecendo em baixo e
nós pareceu falou etapa etapa é e é dado
que se debatam a saudade da minha mãe e
minha mãe seja pela cirurgia uma
besteirinha cozinha besteira e eu fiquei
com ela todo cuidando não ser que hoje
em 1 a 1 até postar a foto com ela no
instagram e saudade mas a minha mãe que
eu vivo viajando não sei o que eu faço a
yoki a minha mãe senhora e se está aqui
é o meu eu quiser me seguir lá já pode
eu estava cuidando dela eu parei pra
pensar assim meu deus estou cuidando de
uma pessoa que coxa e colocou no mundo e
me deu tudo de bom e do melhor por xuxa
e escravizou a vida inteira e muita
redonda escravizá gem nunca saem de casa
já andou dois quarteirão ao escutar mãe
gritavam i 18 boi não vinha correndo com
tudo que foi mandante foi mãe não se
pega bem um copo d'água pra mim vai
falar onde eu pensar que a casa estava
pegando fogo agora eu também me ligava
dela é boi mãe mas aqui pelo amor de
deus é um gente vai ver que foi meu
filho meu que foi apadrinhado do papo
pra mim o ecfa fácil admitiu o meia
ai ai ai gente que não queria mexer não
não e elas têm um negócio com ardor da
casa que quando fica de noite não pode
acender uma luz que não se incomoda é
3oh 3 horas da manhã a meta no dia 17 no
milésimo sétimo som nunca vai à cozinha
beber água acende a luz que está fazendo
e me pareça luiz recorde do rio mais é o
que mantém não pode ser conectada com a
casa é uma luz em cada detalhe ele
acendeu uma luz fica sentindo dela
sempre a mexer quando o cabelo desligar
a luz ela não quer forte manhã seguinte
à lógica do mundo não vale pra mãe não a
mãe terá lógica dela e na lógica da mãe
se ela guardar as panelas ninguém mais
pode comer nada em casa chega em casa 11
horas da noite morrido de fontes a
esquentar um leite para tomar tudo já
vai comer animais que me parece ter
barriga zóia flores que não sobra nada
que em casa se come tudo e noite outra
lógica de manhã o carro tá doente ele
pode fazer nada fica ali sentado fica
ali sentada ou deitada dorme agora o
seguinte se o carro é um sorriso é que
tá bom tá doente há muito assistindo
televisão saltaram piada com um time bom
que está aí todos o rio caminha o que a
mãe não pode ver um filho bom e parado
não tem que tá fazendo alguma coisa pois
quando fui pegar minha mãe fica assim ó
tempo imagino que para ficar parada eu
acho engraçado não sei se vocês já
perceberam mas para nós que são o filho
quando a mãe tá dormindo é o momento
mais sagrado da terra o que ela faz tudo
em câmera lenta
se chegar à visita e mãezinha mais é a
linha do meu coração te amo pra sempre
quis conquistar e acordam chegou a
visita aqui não importa também pode ser
a polícia federal
mas a polícia federal reterá o mandado
de prisão contra chuto de caça para
baixo hoje você me respeita e vilson
autoridade e respeito respeito e chama a
porta que fica com a vaga de contraírem
de pudim e tamanho igual a mim ou chama
larissa time até aqui a polícia aqui e
mãezinha então de policial em anapú é o
maior cuidado do mundo
agora quando é nós que estamos domino
folhas também aí não me 7 horas da manhã
meu amigo levantar o empregado para uma
visita pra mim é falta cantar rock é
engraçado que independente de qualquer
coisa eu te amo essa mulher acaba quando
viesse de fora até do grito dela se você
vai gostar desse vídeo é que gostei aqui
no youtube volta lá no facebook e postou
um vídeo novo é que elas e clique em
curtir lá e marca seus amigos que tem
uma mãe nossa você quer acompanhar eu
vou fazer show filmando tirando foi
direta sob o signo snapfish esquece da
equipe e instagram no instagram no
facebook e no twitter
é nóis 40